welcome back to the worth it postmortem
where we watch old worth it episodes I
was on edge to hear what you call this
show right and it's still unnamed we've
got a lot of contenders out there a lot
of contenders but for post-mortem today
yeah worth it reheated maybe for a work
worth it doggy bag Adam what are we
watching today mmm this is an audience
episode we're watching my favorite
episode
what come on down Adam I'm getting out
of the chair
no actually I'm staying behind camera
you're staying behind camera why cuz I
don't want to be on camera okay but he
does have a mic that he's holding my
favorite episode of worth uh sandwiches
know what sandwiches are you serious
yeah you had not toast sandwiches
sandwiches is just toast with extra
things in the door man just two toasts
hmm this is interesting I'm very I'm
very surprised to see that this is your
episode here's the thing this show much
like your favorite TV shows your actual
favorite episodes are the ones you don't
remember because you have such a good
time watching it hmm I don't buy like
the funniest episodes of a sitcom you
don't remember you were so busy laughing
oh very like the episode that I directed
I was getting to control this one so
that's all true but to be truthful you
do control pretty much every episode so
he's the wizard behind the curtain
maybe music you know what actually a fun
episode we did three cities or if you
include Athens haha huh
I love that so this is the same season
as a eggs in Japan and you could there's
an egg fact where an egg shoots over the
the horizon of the frame and it plays
that same audio cue so synergy Andrew
can you talk about saying that bread is
an important it's a more important part
of the sandwich the contents or the
bread that is a debate we are going to
be putting to bed this episode - bread
not it's mostly gonna be about meat
though because people got really mad
that you said bread isn't the most
important part of a sandwich apparently
a lot of people are mad about this which
Adam informs me now did not know that I
knew that in the comments I see I see
you carpenters
commenters it's not that we don't care
about bread but there's a lot of
different ways to do a sandwich episode
so we just chose to focus on the meat
the sandwiches that we chose for this
episode were a lot more about the meat
than the bread so we just wanted to set
that up in the beginning bolton's is
interesting because there's a lot of
debate about who invented or who first
popularized the Nashville hot chicken
right but Moulton's is definitely one of
the earliest ones yeah I think we wanted
to make sure that we covered a place
that we felt was true to the original
story of the fried chicken rival
sandwich
Adam was really eager to have a fried
chicken sandwich on the show but he was
like there are a lot of places really
capitalizing on that but we wanted to
focus on one of the original places yes
and Bolton's is one of those places
hey I can now see why this is a desert
episode that was very fixed LZ Alan
that's definitely an atom graphic
treatment eh ah I want to eat that right
now
or some people are like sandwiches are
all about the bread like oh wow I really
committed to that perspective I like
bread I like bread a lot yeah right a
lover now you your bread lover and I
think it was just what you were trying
to do was you're trying to make a point
it's trying to start the conversation
yeah you know times gotta be contrary to
make it a competition more interesting
you tend to sweat a lot on this show in
every episode every way and I want to
point this out all in the comments were
saying that I touched my eye on purpose
to make the show more dramatic I am not
in favor of making pain for myself
otherwise I would have started a
different show called and solved okay
but I did a bit yeah we're we get to eat
food around the world and explore
cultural stories in the rising ways not
hunt ghosts no no I did not do it on
purpose you want to watch a show where
people fake it watching soul but yeah a
lot of people accuse you of being like
oh they're just putting on a show but
you were really feeling the pain of this
slice right yeah and that was my muscle
graph a moment
[Music]
so I remember watching the first part of
this and you could not really convey
with just like normal filmmaking
straight documentary style what we're
going through right so I remember Adam
jump on the keys put this little thing
together and the editing Keys yeah right
now the keyboard and that was a very
magical and accurate display of what we
experienced yeah I see kind of a a funky
spooky time that's how I describe that
segment funky spooky oh it was really
hard not to do the same thing that
everyone else does when they're eating
because like hot ones has a very unique
really cool way of visualizing being in
pain from spicy food oh we're filming a
last episode right now all right
so andrew is a friend not of the show
but of the people of the show of us I
actually finished the editing for this
location oh yeah
so because we filmed in so many
different cities you'll see at the end
we go to Japan the editing duties were
spread out among multiple people you can
see the credits at the end but for this
location I stepped in and did some
editing kind of trim
Oh can we eat that please this is one of
my favorite restaurants in Los Angles
he's probably one of my favorite
restaurants period Wow
yeah why why is that Adam it's good the
food tastes good
shameless self gratifying plug okay on
our last day in Japan I went out with
Annie to film city b-roll and just kind
of like randomly stumbled across this
street and this might be my favorite
thing I've ever filmed for the show why
I don't know it's just like the light is
great
the light is great I was trying to find
something that conveyed like the
simultaneous complex density of Tokyo
but also like this silence so it's like
a quiet Street but there's two trains as
a guy in the bike this red car here is a
nice double train double train yeah
there's actually the directions on
different levels there is actually a
third train somewhere else that had run
previously but you can't see in this
shot so we went to this place look let's
talk about let's talk about this think
about how good that for that triple
nipple I don't say how good this place
is we took a one-hour taxi ride to this
place yeah
to film a whatever $2 sandwich and then
a1 Ark actually back home just to film
this location that is the commitment to
making the show good and featuring good
food so it's funny out of all the places
in this episode this is the one where
it's all about the bread you know one of
the weirdest things I will get from
people who are fans of the show is
you're so funny or Wow like you should
be a comedian and I'm like oh no
definitely not at all first of all and I
don't even know how people get that but
I think it's just the comedy of sharing
this experience together yeah yeah I
don't know how to describe the show
isn't
funny but it is funny like we're not we
don't try to be funny but no it's funny
in the way hanging out with your friends
is funny it's not funny
in the way a comedian is funny yeah very
good at them yeah it's like the the
final edit has a personality that isn't
the same as what it's like in real time
it's funny how close this sandwich
mirrors the first sandwich mmm in the
episode you know because it almost
doesn't make sense for it to be between
two slices of bread right it's a very
luxurious thick slice of steak that's a
deep fried brie hiatus and then put
between two slices of toasted white
bread right the restaurant is so small
yeah it's like less than an average
coffee shop size there it is yeah
there's the whole thing like you could
see the menu on the right wall and you
can see the kitchen on the left and
there's a person for scale this is
basically the whole place yeah it's one
table one you know this was a food that
I struggled not to eat quickly yeah I
was like I have this much I can not go
fast I need to savor it that is
something that you're very bad at is
eating slowly and pacing yourself I mean
when you got a wag you Brian cutlet
sandwich one thing that I will say about
this particular location when we shot at
waggy mafia there were many options in
the States to do a Wagyu sandwich right
one in LA there's one in New York but we
decided to take the extra step and go
this is a very intentional move by it
you and I'm one of you guys I don't know
who to go to Japan and actually cover
one of the original locations because
that's important for the storytelling of
the episode right oh this is one I hated
about the shows when you guys suggest
that we do like an ice-cream for it
interstitial because I cannot focus on
talking while I'm eating something
that's melting in my hands it's a
ticking time bomb you'll get all that
fun yeah to be had just want me to eat
ice cream sandwiches that bother me ice
cream sandwich another sandwich that's
not about the bread mmm oh that was
Adams favorite episode a surprise to me
but no longer a mystery you're kind of
right though watching it again I'm like
well there's a lot of great details
about this that I don't remember yeah
man you know you know the last thing
I'll say that was a fun episode I don't
often get left with a feeling of fun
uh-huh but after watching that I feel
fun so if you haven't caught it yet we
just released another work that episode
noodles check that out check it out and
we've got one more coming out this
coming Sunday last one of the year it's
also sandwiches so and then also a week
from now there will be another worth a
watch is so watch that too watch out
worth it well that's what we should call
this worth it watch out
[Music]